Hello, everybody. Welcome to another edition of the holistic health
hour. This is Dr. Kevin Connors. We have several questions to talk
about this. So let's get started. So remember submit your
questions and the course all of our courses, the courses that
allow questions, make sure you use that blue box down at the
bottom to submit your questions so that we can get them answered
or at least as many as we possibly can. First question, can
defects in my genes tell me what I should or shouldn't be eating?
Can defects in my genes tell me what I should or shouldn't be eating?
Well, that is a good question that does not have a perfect answer
because the answer is really yes and no to some degree. So when
you look at your full report, if you did your genetic report
through us, we gave you a full genetic report and then we gave you
a summary report. So the summary report summarizes the genes
that we think you should really focus on. So when I read your
genetic profile, I, you know, gave you the estimate of what I
think really you should be focusing on it. But there's not a
lot of genes that tell us specifically our diet, not specifically.
They give us clues. All of our genes give us clues. Even your HLA
gene. So when we look at gluten, it's really your HLA genes and
your IL221 genes, which are have to do with gluten sensitivity
and with celiac disease. But even if someone has a lot of
variants or defects in their HLA genes, it doesn't mean that they
have gluten sensitivity. It means that they have a propensity to
gluten sensitivity. So it'd be a good idea to maybe cut back on
their gluten. The only way to know if you have gluten sensitivity
meeting you have antibodies to gluten or dairy or anything
else is to do an antibody test. So you have to do an antibody
test, which is a food sensitivity test that is going to share
with you. If you have specific antibodies to gluten or
gleaned or that or the peptides of gleaned and or casing the
protein that's in dairy. So that's a different test. But there are
genes that give us a propensity towards gluten sensitivity and
genes that give us a propensity towards lactose intolerance. So
the the HLA genes are connected with gluten. But again, you could
have double allele defects on all those genes and you still have
no gluten sensitivity. Most people shouldn't be with anyhow,
but that's another story. So it gives it. So I may make
recommendations that you go on a gluten free diet or limit
gluten based upon your genes, but that's not based upon
your antibodies. Likewise, the opposite is true. First,
could have no gene defects in their HLA genes. But they have a
very severe gluten sensitivity. Again, gluten sensitivity is
not so much your genes has to do with your body made antibodies
that really has to do with gut health. And you know, you're in
the core. So make sure you look at the videos or explain all
that. Now, dairy is a little bit different because the MC M6
genes, if you have defects or variants on those genes, you
actually have a greater chance of digesting lactose better. If
you have no variants on that, you have a greater chance of
having difficulty with lactose. So that's one of those variants
if you want to drink milk that it's good to have. So, but that's
just the lactose. So that has nothing to do with the case
seed, which is really the major thing that people have issues
with with food sensitivities. It's not lactose. It's case
seed with dairy products. So it's a protein and the peptides of
those proteins that you end up with antibodies to that you
end up with sensitivities. So, answer to that. Can genes tell
you what you should or should be? Not really, but does give us
clues. One of the best tests to run if I think I might have mold
in my house. If you think if you have mold in your house, then you
want to get some mold testing done with some auger plates in your
house. A good company is immuilinux.com. And I think I list
that on the course. If you think you have mold in your body, then
you really should do the microtox test from great planes. And
you'll see the listing for the microtox test. You could do
that through our store on all of those courses. So mold in your
house versus mold in your body are two different things. You have
mold in your house. That's how you can pick up those spores and
end up having mold issues that affects your health. So you do
want to make sure that you get that checked out and test your
house for mold and get that fixed and corrected through a
professional company as well. Next question I have had kidney
stones in the past. But I don't have any defects in my
oxalate genes. Why? Well, if I have defects in my oxalate
genes, I do increase my propensity to have kidney stones and
or gall stones increase chance of stone formation. If I have a
lot of defects in my oxalate genes, but that's not the only
reason why we get kidney stones. So even if they're oxalate
stones, we still are. Maybe you have a diet that you eat tons
of oxalates. Maybe you eat a large number of oxalates and you
are largely dehydrated on a regular basis. That could be a
cause and a propensity for kidney stones, right there. And
you have no defects on your oxalate genes. So remember,
genes give us clues. They give us pictures. They're not, you
know, give you, you know, this is what you're going to have
because you have this defect. There's a lot of people have a
lot of genes, a lot of defects on their oxalate genes. And
they don't, they've never had stones. They've never had stone
issues. And maybe never will. So that's okay. So again,
genes give us clues. The huge, the huge benefit in running
the genetic profile to me is that you can, you can help
address things before they become issues. So if you look at
your genetics and you have tons of defects in your oxalate
genes, getting on a product like oxalate scavenger and oxalate
balancer can help pull those out of your body before you end up
with a problem can help you change maybe some dietary
things before you end up with a problem and can be a huge
benefit. What is the best way to detox heavy metals? Well,
the best way to detox heavy metals is don't try to detox heavy
metals and tell you address all the other phases of detox
occasion. Most people want to jump right to
key leading heavy metals. What I call phase zero before they
dealt with phase six, phase five, phase four, phase three,
phase two, phase one. And that's where they get sick. So you start
doing key lation of heavy metals. You've never really looked at
your detox genes for phase one, two, and three. You've never,
you know, dealt with your constipation issues. You're not
using binders in your diet to help bind things in the gut. So you
don't re-absorb them. You have a sluggish gall bladder. You have
no business detox in heavy metals. So if you are not in the
seven phases of detox course, think about taking that. That really
helps walk you through all those phases. If you're in the
seven phases of detox course, and you're addressing all those other
phases that I list out in phase zero, that section on the course.
So good key laders that I would recommend.
But make sure you're dealing with those other phases as well.
All right, thank you guys for joining us today. And I hope you
follow this helpful. Know that I'll be praying for you.
And continue to submit your questions as you do because that's
how we'll get them answered. All right, bye bye.